Sofia wants to attend University
but that's not possible
so she signed up for an English course
online
a growing number of virtual schools are
becoming a Lifeline for girls and women
in Afghanistan who've been barred from
secondary and University education it's
a good opportunity for girls for women
in Afghanistan to continue their
education their studies in online
courses so this is why I want to
continue my studies in online courses
Sofia is fortunate to be admitted to her
choice of virtual school it stand down
several other students due to a lack of
capacity and high demand enrollments
have risen from about 50 students to
more than 500 in the past two years
staff members at one online school say
they were concerned about how the talban
might react it's so obvious that if we
want to do a crucial thing if you want
to take an action that is very important
you have to risk and absolutely we
risked everything
the World Bank says 20 percent of people
in Afghanistan have access to the
internet
many can't afford advice or a connection
and services are insecure yeah the major
concern I have regarding our activity is
power outages and internet connection if
one day power or the internet is
disconnected in Afghanistan it would
create a serious problem for us
the talban government began imposing
several restrictions on women after
retaking power following the withdrawal
of U.S forces in 2021. last December
girls were barred from attending
secondary school and universities
the talban Justified the move citing
safety and Islamic laws
Afghanistan is the only country in the
world where women are banned from
education
the U.N children's agency says more than
a million girls have been deprived of
Education since the Taliban took over
it's called a no kanathan's leaders to
allow them to return to school
until that happens women like Sofia
intend to continue getting their
education they want by logging in online